hey you guys time for another flickers
of fear and again we're doing some more
italian jell-o goodness although this
one has a little bit of a different vibe
to it it's interesting because i was
watching like um as kind of a selection
of other uh reviews of this movie
because i always really kind of had an
affection for it um you know i will
admit that it's not you know one of your
top tier giallo movies it's not required
viewing uh you know if you want to get
into the genre but there's something
about it that
really kind of i don't know that really
kind of resonates with me but i see that
in the horror community and particularly
people who are really into italian
horror really into uh giallo movies in
general this one seems to be pretty
divisive um most people are kind of like
you know yeah it's really good one
because of
some of the reasons that i'm going to
get into but then there's some you know
there's a couple in particular that are
really really into glo movies that
really really do not like this one uh
very much at all and kind of put it at
the bottom of the barrel as i said it's
not one of your essential uh giallo you
know it's not essential yellow viewing
by any means but
i don't know there's something about it
i like i guess because it has like it's
not a straightforward yellow film um in
the sense that it has kind of like the
mystery element to it like toward the
end but it also is kind of like an old
school
gothic film like it has a lot of gothic
traffic trappings to it too which um i
actually really enjoy so it's almost
kind of like it almost kind of straddles
the line between
sort of your kind of earlier gothic
movies uh you know like mario baba
something like something like black
sunday or something like that even
though this isn't about witches and it's
not supernatural but it's kind of like
the the dividing line between those
types of movies and kind of your more uh
you know early 70s dario argento uh you
know
more classic giallo movies this came out
uh in in case i didn't mention this is
called the night evelyn came out of the
grave which i love that [ __ ] title i
love diablo titles in general but i love
that title so much this came out in 1971
which was actually i think the same year
that dario argento's uh cat of tails
came out so it's you know the late 70s
early or the late 60s early 70s era was
kind of like the heyday of the giallo
movies once it was kind of getting to
the mid to late 70s you know they were
still being made they were still being
made into the 80s but sort of the heyday
of the mid past like there was a [ __ ]
ton of them made
in the late 60s early 70s so this was i
kind of feel like this was made to sort
of cash in on
on the trend uh but then it still had
all these kind of leftover gothic
trappings to it too which like i said i
kind of like that but your mileage may
vary now this is kind of like the plot
of this is kind of crazy and it's sort
of
convoluted and i think the problem that
a lot of people had with it mostly was
that one you know a lot of the plots it
was just like too off the wall like it
wouldn't have happened like that but i
think the main complaint that i've seen
with it is that a lot of the characters
well pretty much all of the characters
i'm going to say right now are unlikable
because all the characters are pretty
much terrible which in a way i kind of
feel like
you could level that same criticism at
something like you know mario baba's bay
of blood for example where you know
pretty much everyone is a terrible
person who's just out to get something
and will kill people you know to get
what they want so this is kind of like a
similar sort of thing
but you know like i said again your
mileage may vary i really dig this movie
but if you don't i can totally see that
too i feel like there's a bunch of
different versions of this movie uh that
are floating around i believe the one
that's supposedly the most
you know what the director wanted i
guess is a 103 minute version which i'm
pretty sure is the version that i've
seen because there was one there's a
blu-ray set and it's called dangerous
dames or something like that i have to
like look it up
but it has this movie and it also has uh
the other giallo movie that was done by
the same director whose name is emilio
moralia which was called the red queen
kill seven times which i'm also going to
get around to eventually too a lot of
people like i said that are into the
giallo uh genre
will say that of the two giallo movies
that he made like the red queen killed
seven times is the better one but i
haven't seen that one so i'm not really
i mean they are very thematically
similar
so i've heard but since i haven't seen
red queen i'm going to reserve judgment
on that until i actually end up seeing
it
so
what we have in this movie at the very
beginning our main character is a dude
named lord alan cunningham who is kind
of like you're just kind of aristocratic
upper crust like wealthy dude he's
played by anthony steffen which is not
that dude's real name but that was uh
you know that unnamed that he went under
a lot he's kind of an italian brazilian
actor
he um probably most recognizable he was
in a [ __ ] ton
of spaghetti westerns but he was also in
a bunch of uh kind of jell-o and horror
movies as well i knew him from killer
fish
which i actually saw in mystery science
theater uh which was kind of like a
crime uh sort of thing so uh i knew him
from that but i haven't seen any other
like spaghetti westerns that he was in
but he was in like a shit-ton because if
you go to like his imdb page it's just
like there's like two or three columns
of stuff that he was in
but so he plays the main character alan
cunningham
and at the beginning he's kind of like
i don't really know like because at the
beginning the first scene is like
somebody like escaping or something from
like a mental hospital we're presuming
it's supposed to be him but i don't
really know like what the timeline is on
it it doesn't really matter
but so what uh so what ends up happening
with alan
is that his wife evelyn who had who she
was a redhead which is a big part of the
plot
uh she died i believe in childbirth uh i
think it was like a year prior to the
events of the movie uh he didn't take it
too well mainly because
he keeps having these like dreamy
nakedy uh
sequences where
uh his wife is like running naked out
into the gardens and it's like you know
having sex with this other dude uh
you're never really sure i don't think
like whether that actually happened or
not or whether he was like imagining it
because he's not real in his right mind
or it's kind of like i don't know it's
kind of like left ambiguous over whether
he's in his right mind or not so we
don't really know but
so she died
in childbirth and he's uh you know kind
of went batshit afterwards was put in a
mental asylum but he's out now
now
interestingly i guess because his wife
is dead and he
either she really was cheating on him or
he thought that she was he has decided
to
punish her it's really strange like the
relationship that he has because it's
almost kind of like he misses her and
he's obsessed with her he wants her back
but then in a lot of ways it seems like
he's trying to get back at her even
though she's dead and the way that he's
doing this gotta say not a real
psychologically healthy way to go about
this what he's doing is
he goes and picks up
red-headed women usually sex workers
strippers uh that type of thing so like
i said this this is very sleazy i mean
it's not sleazy as like some that i've
seen
but it's pretty sleazy there's a lot of
nudity there's some s m there's some
stuff like that so if if that's like
pinging all your radar it's like then
definitely check this one out cause
there's a lot of that [ __ ] in there
so he'll go and pick up like red-headed
strippers that kind of resemble evelyn
his wife and will take them back to his
uh manor house or his castle or whatever
it is where he has a really nice little
uh torquemada themed sort of he's got
marquis de sade action going on he's got
a big dungeon right and uh you know and
he has a thing for like thigh high
leather boots and it's like so the women
come in there he's like hey put these
boots on and then he starts whipping
them at which point they're kind of like
okay yeah this isn't really fun anymore
and then he uh kills him so you know but
but since he's like a rich dude he kind
of gets away with it it's just very
strange this movie is just very very
strange so he kind of gets away with it
because it seems like no one they're
like well you know he he's he's a rich
dude and that's gonna happen sometimes
and you know he's just he's got some
stuff to deal with so we'll just like
let him do his thing i guess it's almost
kind of like that sort of attitude
so so yeah so he brings a couple of
women in succession
back to his dungeon uh you know puts on
his robes and whips them and puts them
across the thing and they're all running
around naked and you know he ends up
killing him and uh something that
happens too is that
i guess that his dead wife evelyn
had well has has this brother
named albert who still works on the
grounds i don't know if he's like a
gardener or something like that or he
just like you know looks after the
grounds so he still lives and works on
the grounds but he knows that alan is
bringing women back to the castle and
killing them and it's not like alan is
just kind of like oh bringing the women
back and it's like oh my god i'm
freaking out and then he kills him he's
planning this [ __ ] because he has this
whole thing where he has like fake
license plates that just like snap over
the ones on his car and he can just like
you know whip him off and so he's like
you know he's very calculating in that
way it's not kind of a thing where he
goes into a rage or anything so don't
even get that idea
but so the brother evelyn's brother
knows that he's killing people because
he essentially like spies on him so he
uses this knowledge to basically
blackmail him in i think the first time
i watch this because i've seen this like
two or three times the first time i
watched this i laughed really hard
because albert basically comes to him
and he's like yeah i saw what you were
doing with you know that other redhead
or whatever and uh you know alan's like
yeah what do you want this time and he
just says i need 30 pounds and i'm like
you just saw a dude murder somebody
and that's all you're asking for is 30
pounds like to not like rat about to the
police and i called them i wrote a blog
post about this a long time ago i was
like albert is like the budget
blackmailer
i was like oh that seems very reasonable
here you go go buy yourself a pair of
levi's i don't know it's just like very
very funny to me so so yeah so all of
that's going on and also alan has a
cousin i think it's his cousin uh whose
name is george
and
george i guess because
everybody sort of knows there's this um
kind of there's this scene near the
beginning
where
alan brings in
a psychic and they have like a seance in
the castle which like i said that's one
of the things i really like about this
is kind of all the gothic trappings
there's like all this there's like a
family crypt and there's seances and all
this stuff so i love that kind of [ __ ]
you know and ghosts and whatnot i like
that and i like that they kind of like
crossbred the giallo with this sort of
like old-school
gothic hammer you know mario baba type
of sensibility i just thought that was
like really cool it really just i don't
know i just really got into that
so they have this seance evelyn's ghost
seems to appear
uh alan flips out his cousin george is
basically like man you know you're
losing your mind again uh maybe i should
move in and like take care of you
but george's solution and it's like i
should say too that allen also has like
a psychiatrist or something like that
that's like um kind of looking after him
and
both of them seem to think
they're like well probably what you
should do
to stop you from murdering all these
hookers because it seems like everyone
just knows and everyone's just like oh
alan
that's how he's dealing with his trauma
he's just going out picking up
prostitutes
and killing them and it's like no one is
really all that upset about it it's just
so strange so yeah so so the
psychiatrist and the cousin george are
basically like okay well
you need to get out and party and like
get into another relationship because if
you find a woman
that sort of looks like evelyn or
reminds you of evelyn and you marry her
then
suddenly magically you won't want to
kill people anymore because reasons
so
i don't know like i said
it's just but just just let it wash over
you doesn't make any sense it's fine um
and you know i should note too that our
main character who we're supposed to be
kind of i don't know if you're supposed
to be like rooting for him but he is
like the protagonist and
you know the way things go later on like
as the mystery develops
you are kind of like i guess you're kind
of supposed to sympathize with him
because you kind of feel like he's a
victim at some point but i'm like what
you have to
think though is that
he is essentially a serial killer i mean
he's picking up random women in bars and
bringing them back to his sex dungeon
and then killing them so you know that's
not good
but it's just funny how blase everyone
is about it so basically uh you know
george is kind of like this swinging you
know early 70s whatever like with some
terrifying clothes i must say uh but
there's there's this big party like
george takes allen to this big party and
at this party
allen meets gladys
now gladys it's weird because i'm like
reading the wikipedia synopsis
and they're saying okay well he sees
gladys and he's immediately like whoa
you know that's her you know it's kind
of this whole love at first sight thing
and the wikipedia thing says she's a
blonde which i guess she is she doesn't
look as redheaded as the other women but
her hair is kind of more strawberry
blonde so i didn't really know if they
were getting at she was supposed to look
different than evelyn or if
cause she was red-headed enough to make
me think that
maybe
she was supposed to look like i don't
know it's like i'm i'm thinking about
things too much but that's kind of like
what i do i guess so he meets this woman
gladys
and she is played by uh marina malfati
who was in a bunch of uh gela movies uh
like i said if you've seen any number of
jlo movies you will see the same actors
like popping up again and again because
a lot of them were you know the cross
elijah they were in a lot of different
ones uh she was also in the red queen
kill seven times uh you know this same
director's other movie uh she was in all
the colors of the dark which again i
need to get around to because i really
like that movie she was in seven blood
stained orchids which is also pretty
good so you know so if you've seen some
jail movies you'll recognize her
so basically he meets her and decides
that she is the one really i think like
they meet that night and
i don't even remember if it's like that
night or like the next morning basically
he's like hey why don't you marry me and
at first she's like yeah you're crazy or
whatever but then she thinks about she's
like oh you know what okay
it's just kind of like this immediate
okay
uh so yeah so they end up getting
married
like pretty much immediately which is
like really funny so uh so i guess like
i said he's he's marrying her like he
does really seem to
like oh my god she's she's the one i met
her like this is all magical and
everything but it's also kind of like
he's taking the advice of like his
doctor and his cousin and stuff hey you
need to marry somebody uh so you can
stop all the serial killing so there's
that uh going on too
so
gladys who is now lady cunningham
moves into the castle
and
this is very weird okay so you so we
have evelyn's brother albert who still
lives on the property there's also this
other woman this disabled woman who i
think is i just can't remember if she's
evelyn's aunt or if she's alan's aunt
but she kind of works there too and then
there's also they have like a bunch like
a whole a bunch of maids
and they all have like made uniforms
which is not weird but they're all but
part of their uniforms is like these
weird blonde
like sort of aphroe wigs
i'm not really and they don't really
explain it
maybe it's because he gets triggered by
redheads
so
they just put these same wigs on all the
maids so that he wouldn't like look at
him and be like oh my god
you know what i mean so maybe that's
what it was but it's just it was just
funny that it wasn't so there's this big
line of maids and they all had these
they held the same wig on and i was like
okay whatever so uh so yeah
so gladys moves into the house into this
weird ass situation um you know and i
think there's something to do with like
some stolen cutlery or something i don't
know what it is but uh yeah because i
just remember that little detail i don't
even know if it has anything to do with
anything
so
gladys comes in and
the other family members that live there
are like really kind of shitty to her
and as time goes on alan still has and
here's like kind of another gothic trope
that they uh use quite extensively in
this movie is that alan still has a
portrait of his uh you know dead wife
evelyn
and
you know and he's kind of haunted by it
now gladys also starts getting haunted
by it and she starts to get obsessed
with
you know she thinks that she sees uh
evelyn a few times like you know the
ghost of her like at the window she gets
obsessed with going and looking in the
crypt it's like allen doesn't want her
to go in there and she's like what the
[ __ ] is going on in there and it's just
kind of like this whole
thing where for a long time like in the
middle part of the movie you're not
actually really sure if
evelyn
didn't really die
or if she actually is a ghost and is
haunting the [ __ ] or if somebody else is
trying to make them think that evelyn is
still alive or haunting the [ __ ] so it's
kind of like so it's a very much it's a
very very gothic like convoluted uh sort
of narrative now as time goes on
people start uh turning up dead so
albert uh turns up dead the disabled
aunt who i'm pretty sure is alan's aunt
uh she ends up getting killed by there's
like a big pen of one of them like
raises foxes and she basically gets
dumped in there and the foxes eat her
which is nice
and um you know what i mean so so all
these people are like turning up dead
and then uh alan sees what appears to be
evelyn like it's got her little outfit
on that she was wearing in his in all
his like uh naked dreams about her
but she has like it's almost kind of
like a skull face and like skull hands
and she's like beckoning to him and
stuff and he just like totally wigs so
then um
since he like really wigs out this time
they end up having to take him back to
the sanitarium
now after that happens and like i said
from this point forward i'm gonna spoil
it a little bit because the end of it
just goes so bonkers it's one of those
endings where it's like oh here's a
twist you know a scooby-doo twist or
whatever and then you're like oh okay
fair enough and then there's oh here's
another oh but wait and then that's not
all you know what i mean so it's kind of
like it's like a double cross and triple
cross and it's like so there's all this
crazy [ __ ] going on
so he gets sent off to the institution
at which point it is revealed that
gladys the new wife lady cunningham and
george the cousin uh are basically like
we pulled it off bro because
their whole thing was they were trying
to
make alan go crazy again by making him
think that evelyn was still alive or was
haunting him motive being that george
was alan's only
living male relative so he so if
something happened to allen like if
allen like went doolally and like or he
died or whatever then george would get
his entire estate so you know it's a
pretty good motive right there and then
gladys was
kind of helping him out so she was
actually um you know when george took
allen to the party where he met gladys
that was kind of all a setup right so
there was that whole thing going on
now
it's supposedly like at first you're led
to believe that george was the one
dressing up as evelyn like showing up
like by the windows and being like hey
i'm a ghost or whatever but it it turns
out later that it actually wasn't george
it was this other red-headed woman named
susan who you were led to believe
alan had killed like because remember i
said at the beginning like allen was
like totally a serial killer and then he
was like bringing all these redheaded
strippers and stuff like back to
his sex dungeon and killing them so one
of the women that he brought back was
named susan who george had kind of like
introduced him or set him up with and
you're kind of led to believe that she
was killed but she actually got away
so she's been the one that was uh
impersonating uh evelyn this whole time
so like dressing up as a ghost and like
wandering around and [ __ ] like that
so after that happens then it turns out
that george and susan were working
together and then they're like oh well
now we're gonna rub out gladys the wife
so they poison her so then there's like
a fight like they poison some champagne
like they're where they're all
celebrating like how how what a good job
they did like driving allen back into
the insane asylum so they're like we did
it and it's like no now we're gonna
poison her and then gladys and susan
start fighting and then gladys kills
susan but then glad you like she stabs
her i think and then like gladys ends up
dying from the poison so then george is
just like oh well that worked out better
than it could have been expected now i'm
the old last one standing that was like
in on the plot
so you think okay well
the cousin george was behind the whole
thing which like i said not crazy
because he actually did have motive for
getting rid of allen because he stood to
inherit all his money and his property
and stuff but then it turns out in yet
another twist
that actually alan
and his doctor psychiatrist friend whose
name is dr timberlane were actually had
sort of engineered everything from the
beginning to make the conspirators think
that they were driving alan crazy
so that
so he's supposed to like act crazy so
that the conspirators would like show
their ass so there was that whole thing
so alan who i will remind you once again
is a serial killer and his psychiatrist
who basically knows he's a serial killer
and is basically like hey that's how
everyone's got to work through trauma in
their own way type of thing you know he
doesn't say that but that's kind of what
the implication is so the two of them
you're supposed to like be happy that
it's like oh alan he was the victim of
like this supposed conspiracy but really
he was the one that was behind it all
along and he was just trying to draw
them out to get them into trouble
because they were trying to take all his
money away even though again he's a
serial killer so
it's so okay so like i said this is a
very very weird sort of movie so as it
ends up
um
since alan had faked uh you know his
nervous breakdown
to lure everybody out you know and when
this is all revealed like i said in yet
another scooby-doo moment um george
tries to run away and then somehow
accidentally um a big like bag of sulfur
or something like falls into the pool
and then george falls into the pool and
like acid sort of eats part of his skin
off or whatever and so george kind of
gets carried off and that's you know
that's the end of the movie they just
end roll credits no one so everybody in
this movie and like i said i think this
was probably the main criticism of this
movie i saw just like even people that
are like really into jello movies every
single person in this movie
is
terrible that did not bother me so so i
don't really know if like the whole
point of the movie is like oh yay like
alan won because all these people were
conspiring against him but like i said
he's still a killer i mean he did even
though susan who was the second uh
redhead that you saw like him bringing
him back to the sex dungeon and even
though she did live
the first woman that he brings back he
he picks her up he takes her to the car
he he changes out the license plates it
takes her right and he essentially
killed her he's a murderer so
i'm not really sure like why like if
we're supposed to see him as a good guy
because nobody is a good guy and like i
said a psychiatrist far as i know
doesn't kill anybody but he totally
knows he seems to know uh that alan is a
murderer and is not really doing
anything about it but like i said i
guess
because alan is a lord and he has a [ __ ]
ton of money uh i guess he can just do
whatever he wants with total impunity
which i guess is sort of realistic but
you know so uh so yeah there's that
whole thing
so like i said
this was uh one of only two giallo
movies not the only movies but the only
two geller movies that uh emilio morelia
made and he also made red queen kills
seven times which a lot of people have
mentioned was
a lot better than this one the story is
kind of the same but a lot of people
said that was better it's better
directed whatever um i can't really
speak to that because i haven't seen it
i actually really have a lot of
affection for this movie i like the fact
that it goes in sort of a sort of like a
traditional giallo direction
toward the end where it's just kind of
like there's all these red herrings and
it's like all this big conspiracy and
everything it's not so much jello in the
sense that
you know oh there's like a black cloaked
figure with black gloves and he's
stabbing women or it's not really like
that it's more it leans more toward the
gothic it leans more toward you know
something like maybe mario baba would
have made this obviously isn't as great
as a mario baba movie but it's in that
sort of line it kind of reminded me a
little bit of you know like black
sabbath or something like that um it was
that kind of look to it uh the
cinematography is uh quite nice i like
the score a lot uh but this when this
came out in italy it was actually like a
pretty like a you know pretty good uh
not not a huge hit or anything but it
was like pretty successful uh it got
released in the u.s
later like a year later um some parts of
it like i said there's been some parts
of it like cut out because as i said
this is fairly sleazy there's a lot of
nudity particularly in the beginning
part of the movie there's a lot of uh s
m type stuff you know women being
chained up and you know whipped and
stuff like that so you know lots of
boobies if you're into that kind of
thing then you know the the first part
of this movie uh there's a lot of it i
will note too that when this was
released in the united states
one uh the poster that's for it as much
as i love the poster for this which uh
if you haven't seen it it's kind of like
it's a woman in the background like in a
kind of white nightgown type of thing
but she has like a skull head and she
has red hair and then she's like holding
like a severed head
um that doesn't really have anything to
do other than
you know maybe i guess it's kind of like
woman in a nightclub with red hair
that's sort of like scholarly looking
but no one gets decapitated or anything
like that but it's like you know what i
mean so so i kind of feel like when it
was released over here they didn't
really know
how best to market it and i'm not really
sure why that is because it's not like
they were you know new to marketing
these types of movies to an american
audience uh one of the things that comes
up a lot when people are talking about
this movie is that when it was released
in the u.s when you went to see it in
the theater like when they released it
in theaters one of the gimmicks was they
had like red dyed popcorn like you buy
red dot popcorn that's called blood corn
because they couldn't think of a better
name than that i guess but uh yeah so
that was so it was a very kind of like
you know uh was that guy that william
castle is at home thinking of who did
like all the emergo and all that kind of
stuff it was very much that kind of
stuff it was just like these kind of
gimmicky kind of [ __ ] when it came out
but like i said if you like jello movies
this is not a straight-up jala movie it
does have some elements of that um you
know with kind of like over-the-top
kills there is some kind of
it's weird because it's kind of a weird
juxtaposition between like very like
gothic
type of story you know in the classic
sense of the word and then it has some
stuff where it's just kind of like you
know
super mod
type stuff which i think a lot of the
70s uh giallo movies had where they had
these kind of like ultra modern
interiors and everybody had like up to
the minute fashions and that kind of
stuff so there is a little bit an aspect
of that
but
overall it's it has a very gothic tone
to it it's very things like creepy
cemeteries like a creepy old crumbling
castle like and you know in a crypt and
ghosts and seances and that kind of
stuff so it's it so it's just an
interesting kind of like middle ground
between those two genres i suppose even
though it leans a lot more heavily uh
into the gothic but yeah so as i
mentioned there's a lot of different
edits of this floating around although
as far as i know the sort of definitive
one
is the 103 minute version i watched this
on
2b and i'm pretty sure that that's not
cut but i'd have to go back and look at
the runtime because i'm not entirely
sure you know but but it is on to be if
you want to watch it for free i'm sure
it's on other streaming platforms as
well um and as i mentioned earlier uh
emilio morellia who directed this uh and
who also directed the red queen kill
seven times which like i said i will get
around to eventually uh those two movies
were actually released on a kind of a
blu-ray combo
uh called killer dames that's what it
was called not dangerous it was called
killer dames and uh that came out back
in 2016.
and i don't have that but i've heard
that like the uh the print on this
movie in particular is actually really
looks really really nice like i said the
cinematography and this is actually uh
quite cool and i really like all the
sort of gothic elements to it because
you know i'm into that kind of thing but
yeah so as i said if you're into giallo
movies or if you're into like gothic
italian horror uh you might dig it it's
kind of sleazy it's probably about 10-15
minutes longer than it really needed to
be because there's some parts that kind
of drag on a little bit but overall i
actually quite enjoy this one even
though everyone in it is just dastardly
and there's like no one to root for but
i don't know something about it i just
really like the vibe of it it's kind of
a divisive you know among fans of
italian horror in general so let me know
if you've seen it let me know if you saw
what you think about it and we can talk
about it in the comments if you would
like to and that will do it for this
flickers of fear and i will see you guys
on the next one
bye